sup guys it's it's the real rejects he's
Greg I'm John that's Andrew movie source
channel subscribe to that [ __ ] on
YouTube check it out
there's a game based on the Friday the
13th movie series created by Sean s
Cunningham and by proxy the film
Halloween
so they made a [ __ ] video game we're
gonna check it out and Sean Cunningham
if I - Sean Cunningham directed the
first one that came out in 1980 if I'm
not mistaken listen Sean Cunningham
schoen all but you know who's really
cool is Shane Mary Shane Mary said react
to the Friday the 13th game PAX East
2017 you know what Shane that's your
shoutout
that's exactly what we're gonna do today
we're gonna take a look at this [ __ ]
we're gonna make faces while we watch it
and then we're gonna tell you what we
thought about it does that sound good
everybody sounds like a plan
alright this this real reject video
takes place in an Austrian universe hit
the camera
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that were Freddie got cobbler this
one Michael Myers girlfriend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
house
this goes to hell that's exactly that
one
[Music]
Hector
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
why
[Music]
why
all right back come on you can do it
[Music]
poor people
showing us every death
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yes dad I'm making you dude that's a WoW
di was a gnarly [ __ ] trailer that was
Gnarls Barkley man like singing the
progression of all that Jason's like on
the versions were you like Jason goes to
hell and I was really cool in the burlap
sack part - that was pretty cool seeing
all them I wonder if mr. Voorhees isn't
a dude that a girl's job but why didn't
he punch someone's head off like in
Jason Takes Manhattan
we're saving it they're saving okay or
DLC we could stock New York that would
be so good how does this game work I've
read bits and pieces about it I think
you're able to play as Jason and his
campers and if you play as campers you
can play as like a cooperative and you
have to like elude Jason Wow I rather be
Jason what I'm doing the campers you get
to watch their sex scenes yeah Oh could
you kill someone while they're having
sex always whatever I thought we were
gonna see that one of them we're in the
tent
I'm just maybe maybe they don't want to
give all their best tricks away in this
trailer but I've been led to believe
that pretty much anything you wanted of
afraid of 13th movie or love yes it
looks like you can play as Jason for I
mean this whole thing was like from
Jason's perspective yeah but like even
like the cool cinematic touches like the
like the toilet bowl POV well that was
what I was wondering while I was
watching this and I I don't know
anything about what the actual gameplay
looks like beyond these like rendered
visuals I was almost reminder of
Resident Evil and some of those earlier
ones because the angles are so extreme
you see these things happen but it gave
it like a really cool sort of eerie
survival horror quality I wonder how you
can choose how to kill these people
yeah it's like he drives a guy's head
through a spear it cuts off two arms
then their head and like a chainsaw or
something for me one of the more brutal
ones was like that one girl who
just get with the actions that looks
real like because you know like you know
in any movie it's not that easy to hack
a part of money yeah so like that was
actually pretty jarring to watch will
you play it I will definitely give that
a go for sure that looked this looks
this is the first game footage I've seen
in a while that makes me really wonder
everything looks great like the look of
the game looks great the settings look
great the characters look great the
various iterations of Jason and like
Jason isn't even my favorite slasher
it's so cool to see all those now I'm
curious as to what are the controls
gonna be like no it's the gameplay I'm
with you that's gonna be interesting to
see but like one of my favorite game
that's a it's one of the best games just
one of my favorite games to just
brutally murder people is the Thomas
Jane Punisher game that you played on
the first Xbox before the 360 that game
you could just throw people in piranha
tanks you could throw a match them up
into into or have like the what's that's
that the concrete stuff go on and like
dude words are so many interesting
deaths you could like concoct on these
villains punching guys heads off seeing
if you could do a chainsaw dad just
whatever like the options are limitless
I feel for this game like for in terms
of what Jason can do in deaths as four
kills have you guys ever actually killed
anyone though no no not yet I'm telling
you guys it's way better than any video
game oh yeah I mean I've like just torn
people's heads off morning work
everybody there was for a while then I
thought the cops were onto me for a
little bit so I stopped killing some
people used to be safe but I'm thinking
getting back into it you know I felt
like a benefit of a lot you know if you
want to get in shape it's not a better
view you know we move these people you
got a track sometimes you got to run
after them usually I'm carrying
something heavy chainsaw or an axe and
that that's like you're doing cardio and
strength-training and once when you're
going in a body work have you been
submitting max I mean like
acts like some people do action against
trees but into like an actual human body
it's hard to the tree they martyr than
in tree they move around you got to have
great yeah you work more muscles and you
know it's a mental challenge yeah so
this is nothing this is nothing I just
had a blank stare the whole time I was
watching this for [ __ ]
I think that was a better joke than my
in my planned Human Centipede video game
joke so so well done
what's your human centipede joke oh I
was just gonna say something about their
because can you imagine what a human
sentiment video game would be like you
just [ __ ] search people together I
looked up this made me think of actually
it says we're talking about extreme
video games you brought up the Punisher
but you sir played hatred yeah back in
the DIA yes was that [ __ ] in
psychosis game to my life I've ever
played damn this it's hard
yes I've never talked I mean I've seen
plenty of movies that capture my
lifestyle you know American Psycho
whatnot whatever yeah when I played
hatred I was like this is the first
video game where I'm like I can actually
relate to a character for a change
oh I must be super refreshing it was
really refreshing so you know when
you're a serial killer it's got a little
bit is that so many of us this could be
the second game this could be the second
game
yeah the serial killers anonymous no no
no then you're there for life [ __ ] if
you noticed that's a trap you're a dumb
serial killer but in all seriousness if
this game does do really well I'm not
gonna lie it be done for other horror
icon games like do you like do a Freddy
Freddy I'm Aaron Elmo's a Freddy Krueger
game you get in baby room into the
morning
just do a bunch of crazy Freddy Krueger
VR oh I do
Zack that'd be sick I'm a little torn of
this I think Michael Myers make cool
video game Michael Myers you don't make
a cool video games if you made like a
Silent Hill type video game but but a
Hellraiser
mmm that would be [ __ ] sweet cuz any
more puzzles and crazy demonic stuff or
or hear me out here okay a bridesmaid's
video game - you collect puppies all the
way throughout and then you [ __ ] like
after you eat at the rent this [ __ ] on
the street but they do you so damn great
you [ __ ] on do it if you're [ __ ]
like your character slows down you can't
punch his hard
I would love to kill the bridesmaids one
of my weird accent brings it out of us
are you guys excited this is the most
excited I've been about a video game a
long time so we're gonna get back for
that
well I don't get to play very often and
I feel like being a person must work
with horror a lot like this is one I
could realistically see myself actually
picking up the points why I said you're
gonna get backlash now you could explain
yourself yeah this game does look
amazing but if I had to say which game
I'm really looking forward to like I
have to play right now it's the Last of
Us - but that's just the way the last
game ended getting back this I'm really
looking forward to this and hell yeah
yeah and anything that as you said that
you know you can relate to makes me more
excited for you as well so I really want
you to come over and play through so
well I'm excited to try to continue
Metal Gear Solid 4 I'm really excited to
last from the past
pick up Metal Gear and Resident Evil and
you know finish resistance that that
series and you know maybe play like
Bioshock and and also maybe try out like
Grand Theft Auto Forks I started that
game I may be the new Zelda game and I
think what was your good choices I like
him
yeah I just want to get a little bit of
Craig because I know what video game
titles are I'd like to kill you
sometimes but you gotta kill me last
like that sounds oh yeah so I'm calm
about we're trying to figure out who the
killer is the whole time yeah and it's
me
I know it's you thing is I don't know
who's being killed and that's a more
compelling mystery is you know the
killer is we have no ideas died Galba
experiment the album's coming together
watch a youtubers in a building together
if you don't you must each other
channels you must leave my read of your
subscribers or we will delete there is
subscribe to the Rio rejects Sean's
reasons John do the outro John's reasons
to Jerry on Twitter and Instagram he's
also the social media manager
facebook.com slash real rejects at
facebook.com slash Blum house Greg could
be found at the Greg Alba on Twitter and
Instagram
Andrew Gorman is a Gore [ __ ] what's
the ear on it Tom Gorman hey Gordon
Korman dude aliens member do my egg or
7-eleven egg or Sarah Lynn that's right
egg or 7-eleven on Twitter and Instagram
also the movie source channel check them
out give them a subscribe also don't
forget to click oh yeah mentioning that
every time you come to one of our videos
click that bell if you want to see
another video you'll get notified right
when the next one goes up it's the
modern age people live in it be our
guest
once again I'm John this is Andrew has
real rejects cut the camera John all
right cool have a good night